there were 19 hijackers on 9/11 and of
those 19 15 came from Saudi Arabia ever
since the day of those attacks the
family members of some of the victims
have been pursuing financial
compensation from the government of
Saudi Arabia but one of the biggest
obstacles to that compensation was FBI
director and now special prosecutor
Robert Muller it's an important but not
often told story we want to bring you
tonight
Kathie Owens lost her husband on 9/11
Jim Craig ler is her attorney they both
join us tonight thanks very much
both of you for coming on so first to
you first to you Kathy tell us how you
believe Robert Muller has stood in the
way of competent receiving compensation
from the seventh well ever since 9/11
almost immediately after the Department
of Justice which was at that time he was
the FBI director they've covered up and
stifled the investigation into who was
responsible for supporting the hijackers
why would they do that do you think you
know I think there's probably a variety
of reasons maybe you know everyone has a
different reason and they all came
together and a perfect storm for a
cover-up I won't know until we see all
of the documents that are still being
unnecessarily classified yeah he saw Jim
the suspicion that the Saudi government
played some role in the attacks is is
long-standing yeah I don't want to
re-litigate it here but I'm just trying
to get to the nub of Muller's
involvement in this what role do weren't
play so from the moment of 9/11
President Bush's focus was on Iraq and
Saddam Hussein right and he didn't want
to hear about Saudi Arabia's role Saudi
Arabia was an ally in the war against
Iraq and the supporter
and out of the president was good
friends with the saudi ambassador who by
the way he and his wife gave $25,000 to
one of the government agents who were
helping hosnian mid hard the two
terrorists so you know there is this
huge body of evidence that saudi
government officials prepared for the
hijackers arrival helped them got them
money english lessons
safe houses and apartments and provided
the aid without which it would have been
impossible according to the FBI agents
were working the case for the terrorists
to succeed and president bush and
director Muller instead of furthering
that that effort to find the whole story
quashed it interrogations were shut down
documents have been kept secret and that
was continued by President Obama and by
then director Comey in President Obama's
case largely to accommodate his desire
to see the Iran nuclear deal passed
that's right and the reason we are here
and our plea the family's plea to
President Trump is to declassify the
documents there is no reason for
thousands of documents that reveal both
the Saudi role and our own government's
cover-up for 17 years to be kept a
secret and and I fervently agree with
you right and in the darkness all kinds
of theories flower and so it's best to
know and I agree with you completely and
I and I wish you both success in that
Cathy you too thank you for joining us
both of you tonight thank you Peter